hi i'm alicia pasquale pena hi i'm
hadley robinson hi
i'm lauren sy i'm amy poehler we are the
cast of moxie and
we're gonna take a buzzfeed quiz today
to find out
which team movie heroine we are
first how would your bffs describe you
outgoing
optimistic smart reliable confident or
loyal
they describe me
i feel like my friends would give a
different answer than i would
yes right i feel like yeah you guys are
my close friends you guys picked for me
i would pick confident for you oh really
oh
you're all of them i'm smart alicia
you're you're all of these i
am i'm stupid so i'm gonna say smart
freak
you're incredibly smart next question
choose a moxie character that you trust
with a secret
lisa claudia seth lucy emma or cj
who's behind you lauren who's that
little cat person is this okay
i'm sorry this is my child well i'm
gonna pick claudia
yeah seth could probably keep a secret
oh great but this is hard maybe emma or
cj too
i mean lisa lisa would keep a secret
i think she would choose a class to tape
the science of harry potter
the art of the selfie lego robotics
intermediate feminist
literature pop music and politics
smashing the patriarchy 101
lego robotics that just sounds that
sounds like a good time
right yeah that does it sounds hella fun
i'm gonna pick pop music in politics
sounds fun too some of those other
classes i feel like i did take in
college like intermediate feminist
literature i'm gonna go smashing the
patriarchy 101.
i'm going to go smashing the patriarchy
too did you pick one
i think i'm just going to have to do
lego robotics okay next one is
choose a song oh this is a this is a
karaoke question
and people don't know that and on the
wrap party we send karaoke
dancing queen by abba come on eileen by
dixie's midnight runners i want to dance
with somebody by whitney houston bad guy
by billy eilish
umbrella by rihanna and watermelon and
sugar by harry styles that's tough
but i'm gonna follow my heart and that's
i want to dance with somebody but i
wouldn't used him
go too but i was hard loved mama mia but
umbrella by rihanna because
i yeah yeah i'm a horrible singer but
i'm i'm gonna believe in myself and go
with umbrella
you rock it we'd sing it together okay i
have your back
i'm gonna go with bad guy by billy
eilish i feel like
her range is low enough for me to make
that work
powerful woman in real life michelle
obama
oh these are going to be hard dolly
parton my name is lou ruth bader
ginsburg beyonce
all of them buzzfeed this was rude this
question was rude
i think maya angelou okay first love
hopefully
then i will go with ava even though this
is so hard i want to pick all of them
i'm going to go with ava
i might give one to ruth then just
spread it spread the love
i'm gonna pick uh beyonce fellow virgo
and my president choose something
important from
moxie one the student athlete ambassador
campaign
rebel girl by bikini kill the zine the
heart and stars the walk out vivian and
seth's funeral home date i'm sorry
i gotta go with the date very important
to me
this is hard too wow i'm gonna pick
hearts and stars
because every moment is so important to
me it's
choosing between your children here i'm
gonna go grab a girl i'm gonna go with
the walkout
[Laughter]
um hadley who did you get vivian i was
cast
a little quiet but you know how to pack
a punch oh what it's not accurate i love
it
i got olive from easy a like all of
you're an absolute gem
funny outgoing and a bit sarcastic
you're someone who truly lights up the
room when you walk into it
i'm gabrielle union from bring it on
you're forced to be reckoned with you
know what's morally right and you'll do
whatever it takes to make sure every
voice is heard you're smart cunning and
constantly inspiring those around you i
feel like that's you guys
you lady no that's you ah and i
am katie for mean girls
no way you are observant diligent
curious about the world around you
you're someone who likes to learn from
their mistakes
and you come out stronger in the end
you'll always try to do the right things
and your friends really admire you for
it
buzzfeed once again you've read our
minds thank you everybody
for watching and please watch moxie
coming out on netflix
march 3rd thanks buzzfeed thank you
[Music]
you